these people you're talking about are
the ones that sit there and say I don't
care who the leader is I'm going to do
what we want to do what the political
radical left agenda is because it's the
popular one and they stay and convince
the leadership to do it and Goose it
through the system that was one of the
biggest problems in the Trump
Administration and one more thing to
your point is it's not just I understand
and I agree that there are evil people
but there are there's also something
that Tim talks about the banality of
evil there are people that just go to
work and want to go and make sure that
they can go on vacation with their wife
and they want to just make sure their
kids can go to school and get a good
education and they come out of school
and they can get good jobs for
themselves and they just want to live a
normal life so what they want to do is
go to work and not make waves and you
know what makes waves voting for Donald
Trump or doing stuff like that you know